it they saw it as a mess and it's polled
pretty badly which has added to the
political backlash
against it so to some degree she has to
sell this not just
to her party but also to the public on
the back
of what happened yesterday with the eu
who rejected its core
quite the ask i would say so
as intrigued as you are to find out how
she goes there
with that so yes so
we expect that statement i should say
from inside
downing street uh although the sun has
now
come out after a deluge so uh
maybe she'll risk coming out uh uh
in the rain uh now the rain's gone but
uh
as i said that statement is coming in
the next 10 to 15 minutes
she has quite the task on her hand and
we did in fact hear from the brexit
secretary
uh a few moments ago why do you think
that you are not negotiating yourself
you'll have to ask them is the only
realistic deal an ordeal now would
we continue to negotiate in good faith
but we'll also make our preparations for
no deal was it an ambush
yes i think it probably was
i mean doubling there has been quite
outspoken really in his criticism of the
eu
saying that that we just had him saying
it was an ambush earlier on today he
describes some of the behaviour is not
very statesmanlike
it does feel at least like the
brexiteers in her cabinet at least
are rallying around her uh yes
and obviously that's dominic raab has
been one of the most long-standing
brexiteers before
he was in cabinet so it's important for
the prime minister to have and maintain
that support on the flip side of this
argument
i think that in europe they say
what happened yesterday you know
although the tone may not have been what
was expected
the substance the rejection of the
facilitated customs arrangement the
rejection of the idea
of a common rule book has been
abundantly clear
from team barnier not least in a
transcript
of a discussion with mps who went over
to brussels but in speeches
it's been clear from eu 27 leaders
that it has been declined what they did
over summer was decline it politely
and what they did yesterday was decline
it more firmly
and so i think there's a little bit of
bemusement
uh that this has been taken so badly
particularly
given the context that on wednesday
night the prime minister
wrote quite a a sort of hard newspaper
article for a german newspaper
that basically implied we can go no
further
than uh than what than the chequers
agreement uh that's it that's my limit
and i think that that is what i'm told
the eu 27 decided it had to
react the difference here being that the
eu perceives chequers
as a useful tool upon which to base a
negotiation
it signals a a potential landing zone
for the negotiation but is not ever in
their eyes
going to be the end point i think that
is the crucial difference
the prime minister in her article in the
veldt magazine the german
newspaper she said essentially i cannot
go
any further that is what uh we're told
precipitated
some of the backlash some of the
stronger words we heard from donald tusk
and from eu leaders
uh leaving so whether she chooses to
frame it like that
uh when she comes and gives us the
statement that we're expecting
you heard her yesterday in her press
conference say and answer a question
from me
that she felt this was all a negotiating
tactic
um and the big dilemma for theresa may
is yes she now needs space domestically
politically to get it through her party
her conference and through parliament
but she still hasn't nailed it down with
the eu
quite plainly and quite publicly as we
saw
yesterday the question that arises is in
trying to pull these two different
forces together
is it even possible it's a reasonable
question that arises out of the events
of the past few hours okay faisal we'll
be back with you uh very shortly i'm
sure
well let's have a look at what led to
this imminent statement from the prime
minister theresa may was in the austrian
city of salzburg
trying to sell her so-called chequers
proposals to eu leaders
but donald tusk the head of the european
council said
unless that there is some significant
significant progress
at next month's summit there will be no
further negotiations in november
everybody shared the view that while
there are positive elements
in the checkers proposal the suggested
framework for economic cooperation will
not work
not least because it risks undermining
the single market
the moment of truth for brexit
negotiations will be the october
european council
in october we expect maximum progress
and results in the brexit talks
then we will decide whether conditions
are there
to call an extraordinary summit in
november to finalize and formalize the
deal
meanwhile the dutch prime minister mark
rutter slammed
theresa may's organization of the brexit
i think we have made more preparations
for
new for a no deal that the united
kingdom has
but there are of course many issues to
be dealt with
in a no deal scenario many issues and we
are dealing with them one by one
obviously aiming for not needing those
solutions
because we want to come to a deal but we
have to organize for a no deal at the
same time
well let's have a listen to theresa may
now this is her yesterday issuing a
message of defiance to her eu
counterparts she was speaking after a
senior eu official warned
that key parts of her chequers plan
would not work
look the i have always said that these
negotiations were going to be tough
and at various stages of these
negotiations different tactics would be
used as part of those negotiations
what i'm focused on is delivering
delivering on the vote of the british
people and delivering that
in a way which ensures we maintain we
deliver on our commitments of no hard
border between northern ireland and
ireland
that we do so by retaining the union of
the united kingdom and we protect jobs
in doing that the proposal we have put
forward is the only proposal on the
table
that actually delivers uh on that long
step term
sustainable future by offer offering the
free
uh and frictionless movement of goods
across across borders
well someone who was across all of the
uh movements yesterday in salzburg
sky's foreign affairs editor deborah
haynes who joins us and now in the
studio and deborah
why do you think the european leaders
reacted so bluntly should we say to the
chequers proposals
well you have to remember that for the
european union they have got a track
record
of standing firm and playing hardball in
negotiations
and only ever compromising if they're
going to compromise at the last moment
so that could be what theresa may is
facing and we could be seeing from her
you know very much sort of holding the
line standing firm
and standing up to them also for the eu
27
there is the fact that they they need to
demonstrate
the the the benefits of being in the
union
they need you know people like president
macron and angela merkel of germany
they want to make sure that people if
they want to leave
see that they can get you know
punishment um and
turn people off who are maybe also
trying to sort of raise that populist
movement of fracturing the union
so there are those two factors weighing
in and as well
there's the um the very clear divisions
between the two sides
in terms of issues such as the northern
ireland question
and the overriding framework on trade
yeah some big
questions for them to sort out even to
get the that withdrawal agreement of
course there isn't it
the thing that really struck me like
looking at some of the pictures coming
in from
salzburg yesterday was just how rattled
therese may looked it almost was as if
she wasn't expecting salzburg to be such
a big news story for it to be so
explosive which of course has
ramifications for her within her own
party
what was your take on body language
between those european leaders
well the images were really sort of
representative of britain
theresa may being on the outside you
know you had that
sort of that that that image that was on
the front pages of the papers today
of all these men in suits with their
backs turned
and theresa may on the edge in her red
jacket
very much excluded on the outside and
then there was that rather distasteful
perhaps
um photograph that donald tusk posted on
instagram
of theresa may sort of you know trying
to grab a cake from a selection of
of different little tasty cakes and he
sort of put at the bottom sorry no
cherries
and people did really sort of you know
take that take a bit of an affront to
that because
it's you know it's obviously sort of
poking fun at not
cherry-picking in terms of the way that
the british are seen to be
dealing with the brexit negotiations it
almost looked as if he'd set that
picture up deliberately i mean we don't
know but it certainly seemed quite posed
didn't it
it did and it's also you know given
given how high the stakes are
and given the very difficult position
that theresa may is in domestically
it's strange like what is the eu tactic
making it even more difficult for her
which is which is what they have done
not long ago of course until we hear
from
theresa may uh her statement due for 145
sometimes of course these things so it
can
overrun what's your best guess on what
happens next
well i mean people seem to be indicating
that
you know she will be standing firm and
holding the line and reiterating her her
message
in terms of the best deal that she sees
for britain
in terms of brexit what she needs to do
really is
come the next meeting for the eu heads
in october of next next month uh is to
sort of you know try and
indicate that there have been
significant progress in the negotiations
so that this penciled in meeting in the
middle of november when they're all
supposed to come up with
a final agreement to put to their
respective parliaments
actually goes ahead people are very
skeptical that that timeline will be met
okay deborah haynes thank you very much
you're watching sky news coming up we
will be live in downing street where
we're expecting to hear from theresa may
very shortly
hi i'm hannah stott with the latest
showbiz news a warning some flash
photography is coming up
the big screen version of the hit tv
series downton abbey will arrive in
cinemas in september 2019.
the movie will open internationally and
in north america on september the 13th
and september 20 2019 respectively
the original cast including hugh
bonneville michelle dockery
laura carmichael and joanne froggett are
all returning
for the film downton abbey follows a
british aristocratic family in the early
20th century
the series aired for six seasons in at
least 150 countries and set a record for
non-us television shows
with 69 emmy nominations
the future looks female for the marvel
cinema
thing anything no
nothing i think we need to be back up
well that's very loud but it's just that
most
yeah i thought and i can't hear anything
i think that's it that's it i can't hear
anything guys
no nothing here take this one then
and i'll sort this one out
yes sure we just did a cable swap sorry
sir
that's a bit ropey
i am yes
apparently there's a power cut or
something
telephones
um
well that's been the direction of travel
since the disappointment of the salzburg
summit that she has
stood behind checkers in spite of the
fact that the very people
that this compromise was designed for
had rejected it so publicly at the
moment when we thought at least
she was going to get some warm words to
take to the tory conference
with her uh her cabinet colleagues have
been
touring touring these studios and
the tv cameras backing up checkers
uh we heard from james brokenshire
earlier we also caught up with
the environment secretary michael gove
this was what he had to say earlier
today
the prime minister will be negotiating
hard for britain in the days ahead
and her resolution is uh admirable and i
think it's great that the prime minister
is standing up for britain at this time
michael gove there uh talking about his
support for the prime minister
after the disappointments of the
salzburg summit i should say we are
running a little bit uh behind schedule
this was june 4
145 i don't know what's happened uh with
the broadcast technology inside
downing street i'm sure we'll all be up
and running fairly soon but the prime
minister
has a task on her hand a a difficult
task
in any event made much more difficult by
the reaction the very public reaction
of the eu 27 yesterday she has to
persuade the nation now and the
conservative party
and the conservative members she has to
persuade them that checkers is worth
going through with even though it seems
to be so publicly rejected
yesterday i think her great hope here
will be that checkers
becomes a a kind of something that they
can strive towards
that in the actual legal text of any
withdrawal agreement will be
pretty vague something where the finer
details will be negotiated
uh in the transition phase her actual
negotiation
problem right now is uh the related but
different
irish border situation the so-called
backstop we have not presented
further details uh on that uh over the
past few months
eu 27 and particularly ireland don't
like that
she wanted uh she told leo veradkar
to our sources yesterday that it would
be impossible to flesh out the detail
on emerging new proposals that were
floated in outline
uh until november that wasn't good
enough for the european union 27
wasn't good enough for ireland emmanuel
macron backing up ireland
around the conference table at 27
and insisting that there will be no
november summit
to seal a deal unless substantial
progress
is made on northern ireland the state of
play on that though is quite interesting
uh there is new language coming from the
uk
a new language coming from europe so you
can start to see
how a deal might be plausible even
though it looks
pretty bad from where we're standing
right now and it all revolves
around the difference between a customs
border
uh no to that says the united kingdom
and a regulatory border
uh between uh the island of ireland and
great britain now this sounds terrible
uh from the dup standpoint
but it is pointed out and i think some
of this argument is accepted
by uh uk sources that there already
exists some forms of regulatory checks
between great britain and ireland i.e
within the united kingdom i think it's
mainly cattle
uh amazing that to think that it could
come down to this that the entire
deal might come down to the cows that
are transported between scotland
and northern ireland but that is the
foundation upon which
this compromise is now resting which is
the idea
that there are already regulatory checks
between the great britain and ireland
and that's because
across the whole island of ireland
there's a single regime
for agricultural and food standards
that doesn't matter now because we're
all in the european union in the future
that will be maintained
so some of those checks will increase in
fact they will greatly increase
that one of the problems for the man we
just heard from
michael gove so all of this so although
it looks pretty bad yesterday
there still is a route map to a deal
whether the
compromise is needed to make a deal both
on chequers and
with the irish are possible given the
constraints
politically both within the conservative
party and of course
do not forget the dup that is the real
question
it seemed difficult last week it seems
more difficult now
the prime minister has to explain when
we do get the technology working and
statements up and running promise has to
explain how she's going to square that
circle
some uh big questions uh for theresa may
to answer although as you say five so
there's nothing that you love more than
a last minute agreement so i'll have to
watch the space
uh thanks very much we'll be back to you
very shortly
now in the meantime the ukip party
leader jared baton has been speaking at
his party's annual conference
he used his speech to credit ukip with
winning the referendum to leave the eu
and attacked the prime minister's brexit
plans saying that they were brexit in
name
only and what's happened in the two
years and three months since
well we haven't left the european union
yet that's for sure
mrs may and her cross party westminster
establishment have no intention of fully
implementing a complete
exit from the european union if they can
possibly
avoid it they'd like to reverse the
decision of the referendum altogether
but failing that they will settle for
briana
brexit in name only the so-called deal
mrs may wants to achieve is one but one
whereby we pay the eu lots of money
we obey most of their laws continue to
be subject to the decisions
of the court of justice of the european
union and have more or less
open borders that will mean leaving in
name
only if she can achieve that
then it will leave the way open to take
britain back
into the european union in a few years
time
well it's not just eu leaders that
theresa may needs to convince about the
merits of her
chequers plan she also needs to get
enough of her own mps to back her
proposals if she wants to get it through
parliament
and speaking to adam bolton on all out
politics said the conservative mp john
redwood the king brexiteer said that
there is no cliff edge
parliament has legislated just for us to
leave
and i don't think we should be paying 39
billion pounds to the eu
when they behave there is no cliff edge
we will trade with the
eu like the rest of the world under wto
rules as we do for all our business
outside the eu at the moment
and even better news we can choose our
own terrorist schedules so we don't have
to have
the ultra high terrorists on some items
that the eu imposes
we just got confirmation that the prime
minister's statement
in downing street is being delayed by a
lack of power
in a room so let's hope that's not a
metaphor uh for what uh theresa may has
to say
we can go back to downing street where
uh skye's political editor faisal islam
is not having any uh power issues which
is a good news for us
uh faisal how do you think uh
conservative mps are going to take it
if uh theresa may decides to rally
behind st
checkers and and insist as she has been
doing that it's the only credible plan
on the table
well we have heard from some
conservative mps who were
remain voters who were attracted to some
version
that looks a little bit like a single
market that they were quite put out by
what they saw
in salzburg yesterday and they're maybe
they're being pushed in the other
direction on this argument towards
a a canada deal a free trade agreement
not
no special arrangements to keep
sort of integrated at a high degree with
the european union
going forward i think that she still has
some space with her mps
to uh to try to do some sort of checkers
uh
a deal uh up to a point but she's got to
sell it sell it she'll
sell it public it's got to sell it to
the membership um
and the difficulty is uh a fundamental
question it was put
by one mp what is the point of it if the
point of it was to get the european
union
on side was the point of it to maintain
frictionless borders for the car
industry
was the point of it to try to get uh the
irish uh border issue solved
uh all of those uh arguments that
can and will be poured perhaps in the
next few minutes when we do hear from
the prime minister
all of those arguments made more
difficult by the fact that the eu 27
have said
uh uh said what they said uh yesterday
yesterday uh but i still think that if
she can persuade people that that
there's something in it
something to be negotiated then she may
try to continue it but the problem is it
does go
against what she said in that german
newspaper article on wednesday
does she really have more to negotiate
the news on
the issue of migration has gone a bit
quiet we had that
migration advisory committee report a
few days ago
that suggested or was taken as
suggesting
that the home office may not offer any
special
immigration protection or arrangements
for european union citizens after brexit
that didn't go down too well in european
union circles either
they pondering well that will be
reciprocated for uk holiday makers in
france and spain the same arrangements
so that issue well we haven't even
talked about that issue between the uk
and the eu
in terms of the future relationship so
the question is
i think many people felt that checkers
was
a start more compromises would need to
be
made what is she going to say here about
the need to make more compromises
to get anything like checkers through
it's it's very difficult when
both the negotiators from europe and
your own mps
and plenty of the noisy mps amongst them
uh
find the checkers say that the checkers
deal is dead
prime minister we've heard quite a lot
haven't we from brexit
brexit supporters whether or not they're
supporting chequers or not michael gove
dominic robb
andrew bridgen to name a few people who
perhaps we haven't heard so much
from are the more remain supporters do
you think there's an argument that the
odds of a second referendum or even a
general election might have gone up
after
what happened at salzburg well certainly
if the deal doesn't get through
parliament we're in
just incredibly new territory
i mean all of this is new but there's no
form book for this there's no guidebook
a lot of stuff gets thrown up in the air
people think they know what's going to
happen
jacob rees-mogg thinks that uh
everything continues on because of the
fixed parliament act and we just
we just leave on march the 29th and then
uh at that point the sort of government
continues others feel that there'll be
much more of a constitutional crisis
you've heard that from the likes of the
former
foreign secretary uh william hague
i think that the position of the remain
remainers within the conservative party
is very interesting
uh this type of policy czech's policy
was briefed by theresa may to the
remainers and held off
that rebellion that we've all forgotten
about now in july over the customs union
so parliament may well have voted for
uh some sort of customs union resolution
in july were not for the fact that the
prime minister said to those potential
remain rebels i have this chequers thing
in my back pocket
i can maintain frictionless trade let me
give
give me a bit of a bit of space to give
this a go to try and get it negotiated
just give me the space to do this to
negotiate uh
close customs arrangements whilst
maintaining the ability to try to
negotiate
independent trade deals that's the key
uh
sell of checkers if it were possible
if it could be bought by the eu-27 but
the remainers have split a little bit
now
uh the x remainers you have people like
justin greening saying that checkers
doesn't have a future
and she is suggesting pretty clear we're
seeing the prime minister now so we're
going to cut straight to therese may at
downing street here we go
yesterday i was in salzburg for talks
with european leaders
i have always said that these
negotiations would be tough
and they were always bound to be
toughest in the final straight
while both sides want a deal we have to
face up to the fact
that despite the progress we have made
there are two big issues where we remain
a long way
apart the first is our economic
relationship
after we have left here the eu
is still only offering us two options
the first option would involve the uk
staying in the european economic area
and a customs union with the eu
in plain english this would mean
we'd still have to abide by all
the eu rules uncontrolled immigration
from the eu
would continue and we couldn't do trade
deals
we want with other countries
that would make a mockery of the
referendum
we had two years ago
the second option would be a basic free
trade agreement for great britain
that would introduce checks at the great
britain
eu border but even worse
northern ireland would effectively
remain in the customs union
and parts of the single market
permanently separated
economically from the rest of the uk
by a border down the irish sea
parliament has already unanimously
rejected this idea
creating any form of customs border
between northern ireland and the rest of
the uk
would not respect that northern ireland
is an
integral part of the united kingdom in
line with the principle of consent
as set out clearly in the belfast good
friday agreement
it is something i will never agree to
indeed in my judgment it is something no
british prime minister would ever agree
to
if the eu believe i will they are making
a fundamental mistake
anything which fails to respect the
referendum
or which effectively divides our country
into
would be a bad deal and i have always
said
no deal is better than a bad deal
but i've also been clear that the best
outcome is for the uk to leave
with a deal that is why following months
of intensive work and
detailed discussions we proposed a third
option for our future economic
relationship
based on the frictionless trade in goods
that is the best way to protect jobs
here and in the eu
and to avoid a hard border between
ireland and northern ireland
while respecting the referendum result
and the integrity of the united kingdom
yesterday donald tusk said our proposals
would undermine the single market
he didn't explain how in any detail or
make any counter proposal
so we are at an ampass
the second issue is connected to the
first
we both agree that the withdrawal
agreement needs to include a backstop
to ensure that if there's a delay in
implementing our new relationship
there still won't be a hard border
between ireland and northern ireland
but the eu is proposing to achieve this
by effectively keeping northern ireland
in the customs union
as i have already said that is
unacceptable
we will never agree to it it would mean
breaking up our country we will set out
our alternative
that preserves the integrity of the uk
and it will be in line with the
commitments we made back in december
including the commitment that no new
regulatory barriers should be created
between northern ireland and the rest of
the uk
unless the northern ireland executive
and assembly agree
as i told eu leaders neither side should
demand the unacceptable
of the other we cannot accept anything
that threatens the integrity of our
union
just as they cannot accept anything that
threatens the integrity of theirs
we cannot accept anything that does not
respect the result
of the referendum just as they cannot
accept anything that is not in the
interests of their citizens
throughout this process i have treated
the eu
with nothing but respect
the uk expects the same
a good relationship at the end of this
process depends on it
at this late stage in the negotiations
it is not acceptable
to simply reject the other side's
proposals
without a detailed explanation and
counter proposals
so we now need to hear from the eu
what the real issues are and what their
alternative is
so that we can discuss them until we do
we cannot make progress
the meantime we must and will continue
the work of preparing ourselves for no
deal
in particular i want to clarify our
approach to two
issues first there are over three
million
eu citizens living in the uk who will be
understandably worried about what the
outcome of yesterday's summit
means for their future i want to be
clear with you
that even in the event of no deal your
rights will be
protected you are our friends our
neighbors
our colleagues we want you to stay
second i want to reassure the people of
northern ireland
that in the event of no deal we will do
everything in our power to prevent a
return to a hard border
let me also say this
the referendum was the largest
democratic exercise
this country has ever undergone to deny
its legitimacy
or frustrate its result threatens public
trust in our democracy
that is why for over two years i have
worked day and night
to deliver a deal that sees the uk leave
the eu
i have worked to bring people with me
even when that has not
always seemed possible no one wants a
good deal more than me
but the eu should be clear i will not
overturn the result of the referendum
nor will i break up my country
we need serious engagement on resolving
the two
big problems in the negotiations
and we stand ready
theresa may uh they're giving her
reaction to that summit uh
in salzburg saying that she will not
overturn the results of the referendum
or break up the country she also had
some pretty strong words to
uh eu leaders saying i have treated the
eu with nothing but respect
the uk expects the same back well
let's bring in faizal islam our
political editor who's been
looking through uh and listening along
with the rest of us to what the prime
minister
had to say and it was pretty clear
wasn't it from what therese may
was saying that they are at a total
impasse
that there is no progress effectively
that's been made
on some of those key issues including
the future economic relationship
and also of course that tricky irish
border backstop issue
yeah fighting talk there from the prime
minister defending her chequers
proposals and i think there was uh
you know asking the eu essentially to
show
her and the british people some respect
in terms of the negotiations
i think there was some news in there as
well i detected there a sort of
unilateral guarantee in the event of no
deal to eu citizens saying their rights
would be protected
that is language we have not necessarily
had before when that question has been
asked it's an obvious question
that if you're preparing for no deal as
a government should eu citizens the
three million of them should they also
prepare for no deal
because all of that agreement that was
settled uh uh
months ago now almost a year ago was
contingent on a deal being done so it's
a very real question
for millions of people as to whether as
to what applies
she has now said to three million eu
citizens in the uk
that their rights will be unilaterally
uh protected
even if there's no deal which is an
important guarantee she said that was a
direct
result of what happened yesterday
remember there was a big controversy it
said by the cabinet at the time that
the day after the brexit referendum
simon cabinet wanted to do that
and they pointed the finger frankly
towards the home office
as to why that was not the case but
still it's happened
now prime minister sending a message to
eu citizens that their rights
are uh protected but strong words about
uh the issue of both the chequers
agreement
and the i the irish backstop
she said that the eu proposals
either would offer uncontrolled
migration to continue
and make a mockery of the referendum or
would lead
to a division within the united kingdom
which would lead to permanent
economic separation both she rejects
both she could not accept as prime
minister
anything which fails to respect the
referendum or divides our country and
that's a reference to the current
incarnation
of the european union version of the
backstop agreement will be a bad deal
and she says she reminds us that a bad
deal she's always said
is that no deal i should say is better
than
a bad deal now however
if you read very carefully what she said
about her backstop arrangement the
text that she has now promised on camera
to bring forward
she says that there will be no customs
barrier
between great britain and northern
ireland
but she left open the notion that there
could be
a regulatory barrier if the northern
ireland assembly
agrees to it so i think what we got
there
was a hint that if the northern irish
politicians at the assembly remember the
assembly is not up and running
but if they did agree to further
regulatory
divergence on the island of ireland
designed to converge
northern ireland with the republic and
the rest of the eu
if that was agreed in a devolved way
that could be an acceptable part of the
united kingdom
offer on a uh withdrawal
on a withdrawal agreement irish backstop
so to reiterate this would not be
a customs border but it would be a type
of
regulatory border building on what i
told you before
already exists frankly for cattle
adding to that other areas under the
consent
of the northern irish assembly under
devolution
arrangements so she's hinting i believe
i haven't had any briefing on this
we haven't been able to ask questions
about it but i think she's
clearly signaling a way forward
on northern ireland that she hopes will
be accepted
now i don't see how the europeans would
accept that northern ireland would be
part
of a different would have different
tariffs um and different customs
arrangements
but then again i don't see how the dup
and tory brexiters would accept northern
ireland essentially not being part
of future trade deals which would be
great britain only
and not uk wide so there's the dilemma
but there's the compromise she's hinted
at so yes tough
fighting talk about refusing
the offers on the table from the eu but
pointing towards compromises compromises
on what might be seen by some as a
regulatory border
in the irish sea and an offer to eu
citizens
effectively unilaterally to maintain
their rights
even if there is no deal thank you uh
fires of very
interesting stuff and as you were saying
a very different demeanor from uh
theresa may compared to
yesterday well let's bring in our
foreign affairs editor
uh debra haynes who's also listening to
that i mean it was
she was a very different woman if you
like from that press conference
yesterday she seemed rattled then today
she came out swinging and she had some
pretty
stern words directed at the eu leaders i
thought as well i have treated the eu
with nothing but respect
the uk expects the same and she also
effectively said
that we need to hear an alternative plan
from the eu and unless they come up with
something there'll be no progress
absolutely she's very much um hitting
the ball back into the eu's court
um i thought it was interesting um how
she said in you know in this stage of a
negotiation
when you know you're right down to the
to near to the finishing line
um it's not acceptable simply to
reject a proposal from one side without
offering
some kind of proposal on your side and
so she's sort of saying to them you know
you can't just reject the checkers
proposals
without a detailed explanation as to why
it's being rejected
and and offer some alternative some way
forward because
the way things were left yesterday was
it was still up to
theresa may to come up with some sort of
solution to make this make this magic
work
and she's very much holding her line
saying they've budged they're
you know they've they you know the uk
side has been willing to
move on on their red lines and there's
been nothing
from the eu and i think this is a moment
when we
really see whether or not the uk
is this big power in europe are we big
enough
are we big enough of a country for it
for them to actually
care that she's saying this or have we
actually been so marginalized that she
can
stamp and shout all she likes but
they're still not going to budge
and we're going to crash out are we just
going to get another jokey instagram
post from
donald tusk i suppose that you know is
the question i mean i guess could the
eu argue that they have actually put
some proposals forward they have offered
for example
a customs union eea star relationship
that she doesn't want to see because it
would mean free movement
of people and abiding by eu rules or a
basic free trade deal that again theresa
may has rejected because it would mean a
effectively a border in the rsc well
exactly and i thought it was really
interesting that when she sort of summed
up about about that she sort of said how
you know you it's it's not sensible to
come up with um
solutions that are unacceptable to to
you know to the youth so they should
have known that basically
but then equally she said which i
thought was interesting that you know
obviously on the uk side they can't come
up with proposals that would be
unacceptable
to the eu that would challenge the
integrity of the eu
but you could imagine the eu sort of
saying well brexit does challenge the
integrity
of the eu so the very fact that we're
leaving
actually doesn't meet that that sort of
um
the description that she sort of set out
are you
getting a sense of a kind of
relationship breaking down because it
did
feel as if she was very frustrated and
perhaps slightly
offended if you like by perhaps the way
that she
at least perceives that she's been
treated by the european union